gemeinsame ziele und interner streit die
linke sucht auf ihrem parteitag nach
einem kurs mit dem sie bei der
bundestagswahl punkten kann ein skandal
weitet sich aus die rechtsextreme chat
gruppe hessischer polizisten war größer
als bisher bekannt
keiner rein und keiner raus portugal
riegelt seiner hauptstadt weitgehend ab
um die korona delta mutation in den
griff zu bekommen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen guten abend
dieser nachrichten samstag im überblick
an dem ihr auch für die deutsche fußball
nationalmannschaft einiges auf dem spiel
stehen christin erst recht in dieser
gruppe guten abend mehr zu ihm natürlich
später im sport die internen streits
beenden geschlossen für einen erfolg bei
der bundestagswahl kämpfen das ist die
losung der parteiführung der linken
heute ist parteitag es geht um das
wahlprogramm aber auch um schlechte
umfragewerte und die diskussionen über
den richtigen kurs heike slansky hat
mehr dazu aus berlin einen politischen
richtungswechsel fordert die linke
umverteilen von oben nach unten eine
vermögenssteuer zum beispiel für einen
höheren mindestlohn das sei sozial
gerecht so die spitzenkandidatin
die linke es die die hartz4 beratungen
in den büros anbietet und damit eben
auch praktischen unterschied macht und
ein konkretes angebot für menschen die
von sozialer not und von armut betroffen
sind
die parteiführung will raus aus der
opposition strebt ein grün rot rotes
bündnis an hauptknackpunkt die
außenpolitik manche an der basis
kompromisslos wir fordern den abzug
aller us truppen und den abzug und die
zerstörung der atombomben und das ist
unstrittig wir müssen viel offensiver
die unverantwortliche politik der
aufrüstung und auch der ja
konfrontationspolitik der nato und der
eu gegen russland und gegenüber china
skandalisieren rund 580 delegierte fast
alle online mehr als 1000
änderungsanträge für das wahlprogramm
das morgen wird debattiert und
abgestimmt
die parteivorsitzende gibt sich trotz
parteiinterner streitigkeiten und
schlechter umfragen kämpferisch mahnt
zur geschlossenheit
wir gehen nicht zu boden und wir werden
es nicht tun weil wir zusammenhalten
weil wir geschlossen sind
wir sind die partei die linke wir sind
im klassenkampf und klassen sind nichts
abstraktes wie sozial- und klimagerechte
slogan
mit dem sie in den wahlkampf ziehen
sollte nicht besonders rund gerade bei
der linken und das kurz vor der
bundestagswahl andrea maurer beobachtet
für uns den parteitag
hallo andrea wie zeigt sich dass dort ja
das zeigt sich hier vor allem an dem was
die partei chefin susanne hennig will so
in ihrer eröffnungsrede selbst
verunsicherung genannt hat die partei
sei in einer situation wo viele sagen
wofür brauchen wir euch eigentlich noch
die parteispitze setzt jetzt wir haben
es in dem beitrag gesehen voll auf die
soziale frage und aufgeschlossenheit
diese botschaft soll nach außen gehen
aber auch nach innen an innerparteiliche
kritiker etwa wie sahra wagenknecht die
ja ihrer partei vorwirft die soziale
frage zugunsten von identitätspolitik zu
vernachlässigen aber auch an
wagenknechts ehemann oskar lafontaine
der in den letzten wochen für
kontroversen gesorgt hat wie besorgt die
parteispitze über diese
innerparteilichen streitigkeiten ist das
zeigt sich auch daran dass susanne
hennig welt so gestern noch also kurz
vor dem parteitag ins saarland gefahren
ist zu gesprächen mit lafontaine
der sei versöhnlich heißt es heute über
den inhalt des gesprächs aber wollen
beide seiten nicht sagen
hintergründe live aus berlin von andrea
maurer wäre vielen dank dafür
unser nächstes thema jetzt vergangene
woche erst hatte hessens innenminister
peter beuth das spezialeinsatzkommando
der frankfurter polizei aufgelöst weil
beamte in chats rechtsextreme inhalte
ausgetauscht hatten
doch die dimensionen des ganzen sind
noch viel größer inzwischen ist klar es
waren 49 polizisten in der jet gruppe
darunter beamte des hessischen
landeskriminalamts und verschiedener
präsidien überwiegend aber mitglieder
des sek
pikantes detail 13 von ihnen waren im
dienst während des rassistischen
anschlags von hanau
besonders in china berichtet 16 monate
nach dem terror fand heute auch eine
kundgebung vor dem polizeipräsidium in
offenbach statt das für hanau zuständig
ist denn klar ist jetzt auch in dieser
polizeistation waren beamtin rechten
chat gruppen vor allem die angehörigen
fordern auf
sie hatten immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass sich die polizei in der
tatnacht in ihren augen rassistisch
verhalten habe wenn man einen schwer
verletzten der verbluten ist erst noch
ein personalausweis fragt wenn man
überlebende die da drin waren es
mitbekommen haben nach hause schickten
weg schickt dann wundert mich gar nichts
mehr
auch nicholas cooper hatte nach der tat
befremdliches erlebt sein sohn willi
hatte den täter verfolgt und dafür mit
seinem leben bezahlte für seine
zivilcourage wurde er gestern post oben
vom land hessen ausgezeichnet
der vater sagt er habe gehört wie ein
polizist äußerte er hätte nicht gedacht
dass ein [ __ ] zivilcourage haben
könnte um die andere lacht so eine
primitive mentalität insgesamt sind es
nur 49 polizisten aus acht hessischen
polizeibehörden den rechten chat gruppen
unter anderem nazi-symbole austauschten
der hessische innenminister peter beuth
gerät immer mehr unter druck betonte
aber gegenüber dem zdf dass er
entschlossen durchgreifen
es sei ein eklatantes führungsversagen
offenkundig da sek beamte mit
führungsfunktion in den besagten chats
vertreten waren und nicht gehandelt
haben
die opposition vermisst beim
innenminister eine eigene fehlerkultur
wenn sich dinge nicht mehr vertuschen
lassen
dann sind immer andere schuld er
versucht immer die verantwortung
abzuschieben erlebt diese fehlerkultur
nicht vor und er muss sich auch selbst
fragen ob er den herausforderungen die
jetzt der polizei bevorstehen gewachsen
ist wir sagen er seine aufgaben nicht
gewachsen herr beuth sollte seinen hut
nehmen doch das lehnt der innenminister
ab fest steht mit den 49 polizisten den
rechten chats sind es mittlerweile mehr
als 100 hessische beamte gegen die wegen
rechtsextremismus verdachts ermittelt
wird
wichtige nachricht für alle hausbauer
nach zdf informationen will die
bundesregierung jetzt doch darauf
verzichten
bei neubauten ein solardach zur pflicht
zu machen diese vorschrift sollte
eigentlich ab übernächstem jahr
eingeführt werden
nach beratungen in den zuständigen
ministerien über das klimaschutzprogramm
ist das thema aber jetzt vom tisch das
kabinett will das gesamtpaket am
mittwoch beschließen
und jetzt hier bei uns das thema corona
und ein weiterer erfreulicher trend die
bundesweite inzidenz ist zum ersten mal
seit september wieder unter zehn
gesunken
das robert koch institut meldet 1108
neuinfektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 8 103 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 99 menschen starben binnen 24
stunden in zusammenhang mit dem virus
die sieben tage incidents liegt jetzt
bei 9,3 trotz der sinkenden
infektionszahlen rufen virologen dazu
auf die delta variante des corona virus
ab sofort sehr ernst zu nehmen
christian drosten von der charité sieht
deutschland im rennen mit der
hochansteckenden virus mutation auch
sein frankfurter kollege martin stürmer
warnt davor den schutz vor corona zu
schnell zu lockern
in seinem labor sei mittlerweile ein
viertel der positiven tests auf die
delta variante zurückzuführen
portugal zieht bereits konsequenzen um
die ursprünglich aus indien stammende
mutation einzudämmen ist der großraum
lissabon seit gestern abend abgeriegelt
die rund 2,8 millionen bewohner dürfen
die region nun auch aus triftigem grund
verlassen
von draußen darf man nur noch in
ausnahmefällen rein
die delta variante hatte sich sprunghaft
ausgebreitet wie miriam stein berichtet
die leute in lissabon bleiben an diesem
wochenende unter sich
es ist ein star ist kein hausarrest
fußballgucken in der bar geht die public
viewing veranstaltungen sind aber
abgesagt
das spiel bei freunden dort sind wir nur
zwei paare und könnten zusammen
ich finde es gut die zahlen gegen hoch
und das könnte der weg sein die
ansteckungen zu verringern
eigentlich war portugal auf einem guten
weg der einstige corona hotspot hatte
seit dem frühjahr mit die niedrigsten
zahlen in europa doch dann kam die delta
variante des virus und trifft vor allem
lissabon an einem tag gab es so viele
neue infizierte wie seit februar nicht
mehr in lissabon gibt es viele migranten
und touristen also mehr leute die
potenziell leichter fälle importieren
können und außerdem haben wir hier das
problem der bevölkerungsdichte es gibt
mehr leute mehr veranstaltungen das
nachtleben könnte also ein grund seien
auch dafür dass sich vor allem junge
menschen infizieren
die sind auch häufig noch nicht geimpft
von den zehn millionen portugiesinnen
und portugiesen sind 46 einmal 25
prozent vollständig geimpft wie die
variante nach lissabon kam ist noch
nicht klar
natürlich könnte es sein dass ein
britischer tourist sie mitgebracht hat
aber ich glaube nicht dass das relevant
ist
es ist nur eine frage der zeit bis diese
variante in europa und auf der welt
dominant sein wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass
lissabon auch kommendes wochenende
wieder abgeriegelt wird
die polizei hat eine party im hamburger
stadtpark aufgelöst rund 4000 menschen
feierten vergangene nacht bei
sommerlichen temperaturen und achteten
nicht immer auf die korona wege die
polizei griff ein und räumte das gelände
dabei wurden zwei beamte verletzt
geflüchtete kinder und jugendliche
gehören zu den großen verlierern der
korona pandemie das sagt das deutsche
kinderhilfswerk dass kitas und schulen
zu wahren habe bei ihnen vielfach dazu
geführt dass sie sprachlich und auch
schulisch weit zurückgeworfen wurden das
lernen zu hause ohne hilfe der eltern
und oft ohne ausreichende technische
ausstattung in einer
gemeinschaftsunterkunft funktioniere
nicht
jetzt unser nächstes thema die
politische zukunft im iran und die damit
verbundenen fragen für die welt
der sieger der iranischen
präsidentschaftswahl steht fest es ist
wie erwartet der bisherige justizchef
ebrahim reich sie
er gilt als konservativer geistlicher
und hardliner war ich sie folgt auf den
eigentlich als eher gemäßigt geltenden
hasani viele iraner waren gar nicht erst
zur wahl gegangen die opposition von der
viele kandidaten von vornherein
ausgeschlossen waren hatte zum boykott
der wahl aufgerufen jörg brase es kam
genau so wie es alle erwartet hatten
noch am vormittag traf wahlsieger rief
sie den amtierenden präsidenten rohren
man werde einen geordneten übergang
organisieren versprach easy und bedankte
sich für das vertrauen
ich bin ein diener des volkes und ich
hoffe dass ich den erwartungen im laufe
meiner amtszeit gerecht werden kann
auf jeden fall will ich auch die
erfahrungen der bisherigen regierung
nutzen
bereits am frühen morgen nach auszählung
eines kleinen teils der stimmen war klar
dass sie mit großem vorsprung gewinnen
würde
mit spannung erwartet wurde die höhe der
wahlbeteiligung
bis zu 28 millionen 600.000 unserer
geschätzten bürger haben an dieser wahl
teilgenommen
das entspricht einer beteiligung von nur
rund 48 prozent
die meisten blieben aus protest oder
desinteresse zu hause auf teherans
straßen freuten sich heute nur wenige
receiver als justizchef erfolgreich ich
hoffe er wird auch als präsident
erfolgreich sein
das ist alles ein falsches spiel es war
vorher klar dass reise gewählt wird das
hätte ihnen jeder sagen können die vier
anderen kandidaten waren nur damit man
dieses theater spielen konnte irans
staatsoberhaupt religionsführer ali
chamenei lobte den großen zuspruch für
reise doch der wird ein volk regieren
dessen absolute mehrheit den neuen
präsidenten ablehnt
wir gehen jetzt live nach teheran new
york was bedeutet denn der neue mann für
irans politik gegenüber der welt
vermutlich wird sich da gar nicht so
viel ändern denn die außenpolitischen
entscheidungen trifft der präsident
geschweige denn der außenminister
sondern ganz allein das religiöse und
politische oberhaupt ayatollah ali
khamenei
so ist es also unwahrscheinlich dass es
zu einer annäherung an die usa oder
israel kommen wird ganz im gegenteil
auch könnte das land sich von
europaweiter abwenden und mehr
richtungen china tendieren in einer
sache aber sind auch die hardliner sehr
pragmatisch nämlich in bezug auf das
atom abkommen rra sie hatte im wahlkampf
versprochen dass er sich an das atom
abkommen gebunden fühlt und so glaubt
man dass die laufenden verhandlungen in
den nächsten wochen zum erfolg geführt
werden könnten denn auch sie möchte dass
die us-wirtschaft sanktionen aufgehoben
werden denn iran braucht dringend
frisches geld
jörg brase zdf teheran dankeschön ein
neuer nationaler feiertag heute in den
usa der jones day erinnert an das ende
der sklaverei in vielen städten feierten
menschen den gedenk tag ein
entsprechendes gesetz hatte präsident
joe biden vorgestern unterzeichnet
am 19 juni 1865 zwei monate nach ende
des amerikanischen bürgerkriegs war die
freilassung aller sklaven verkündet
wurde nach deutschland endlich ferien
endlich wieder urlaub schleswig holstein
und mecklenburg vorpommern sind als
erste bundesländer in die schulferien
gestartet bei hohen temperaturen und
niedrigen inzidenz zieht es viele ans
meer
doch bevor es dort voll wird ist es erst
mal eng auf der autobahn auf der a1
richtung ostsee ging es schon heute
morgen nur noch sehr zäh voran
und damit sind wir beim sport christin
und der frage deutschland portugal ist
die chance sehr erfreulich und verdient
3 2 1 für deutschland beide mannschaften
wissen natürlich dass weltmeister
frankreich vor hingegen forsch
aufspielen der ungarn nicht über ein 1 1
hinausgekommen ist vor einer kulisse in
budapest in diesen endrundenturnier
einzigartiges
[Applaus]
1000 besucher in der fast vollen puskas
arena begeistern sich an einer
exzellenten kämpferischen leistung der
ungarn ein starker spielzug über sechs
stationen bringt ihnen kurz vor der
halbzeitpause das 1 0 durch
außenverteidiger ortega fiola die
hungern zwar lediglich mit 37 prozent
ballbesitz aber extrem leidenschaftlich
unter anderem auch beim jubeln über
ihren treffer
frankreich bringt den außenseiter
überraschend selten in bedrängnis hat
nur eine handvoll guter torchancen auf
vorarbeit von bp gleich nach 65 minuten
andreas mann aus der angreifer des fc
barcelona trifft mit seinem ersten
torschuss der weltmeister blieb unter
seinen möglichkeiten ist im gegnerischen
strafraum nicht präzise genug der gute
torwart gulati steht ihrem erfolg im weg
der schlussmann von rb leipzig feiert
das eins zu eins in budapest mit seinen
ungarischen kollegen wie einen sieg zur
formel 1 da geht in frankreich der
spannende zweikampf des spitzenduos in
die nächste runde
der wm-führende max verstappen aus den
niederlanden sichert sich im red bull
die pole position für das siebte
saisonrennen vor weltmeister lewis
hamilton im mercedes sebastian vettel
startet morgen von platz zwölf drei
plätze dahinter rangiert nach einem
unfall mit schumacher und noch zum
tennis atp rasenturnier in halle
westfalen eine wichtige generalprobe für
das dritte grand-slam-turnier des jahres
rumpelten allerdings kein deutscher mehr
dabei erstes halbfinale das duell zweier
freunde
der georgier nikolaus basilea chemie und
der russe andrej wroblewski sich
guthaben schon viermal gegeneinander
gespielt die bilanz ist ausgeglichen 2 2
und entsprechend ausgeglichen ist es
auch heute
koblet dominiert den ersten satzgewinn
team deutlich mit 6 zu 1 im zweiten
durchgang aber hat der russe häufig mit
sich selbst verliert den faden und mit 6
zu 3 den sack sun wieder stillen
frisch gestärkt ist er im
entscheidungssatz dann aber wieder der
bessere von zwei sehr guten spieler
gewinnt das match in drei sätzen und ist
morgen gnade gegen den franzosen
ob das so bleibt morgen live hier bei
uns kurz nach zwei danke christian ist
das kunst oder kann das weg das ist die
große frage an der autobahn 7 nahe
rothenburg ob der tauber
dort hat ein autofahrer dieses wertvolle
ölgemälde eines rembrandt schülers
gefunden
gleich daneben lag noch ein
selbstporträt des italienischen
künstlers belotti beide werke sollen
rund 350 jahre alt sein
was machen die in einem mülleimer an der
autobahnraststätte und wem gehören sie
wenn sie also die beiden männer erkennen
die polizei freut sich über jeden
hinweis das wetter sollten im auge
behalten
es gibt eine aktuelle unwetterwarnung
für brandenburg und berlin mehr gleich
von osten terry
dann empfehle ich ihnen natürlich das
heute journal um 23 uhr 15 mit der
kollegin marietta slomka wir alle im
team heute 19 sagen danke für ihr
interesse gerne bis morgen und in allen
ein sehr angenehm haben
[Musik]
ein schoko rammte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die ursache für
die hitzewelle waren bisher tiefste
hauptsächlich im westen waren und auf
ihrer vorderseite kann die hitze
teilweise von nordafrika zu uns dass es
morgen auch noch mal der fall bis 36
grad steigen die werte im osten
deutschlands aber auch dieses kleine
tief erreicht uns und wird im laufe der
kommenden nacht bereits heftige gewitter
auslösen
es wird ziemlich mild bleiben in der
nacht 21 grad im rhein main gebiet und
im südwesten eine tropische nacht
kühlsten ist es mit 11 bis 13 grad im
nordwesten an der nordsee ja und in der
nacht in der zweiten nachthälfte kommen
heftige schauer und gewitter auf teils
mit größeren hagel sturm oder
orkanartigen böen sind durchaus möglich
im osten ist es erst einmal trocken und
aufgelockert morgen im tagesverlauf
ziehen die schauer und gewitter erst
einmal weiter nach nordosten
ja und von südwesten her am nachmittag
neue heftige gewitter eine ordentliche
unwetterlage das mit temperaturen bis 36
grad im osten und 25 grad bis 26 grad im
westen deutschlands
die nächsten tage weitere unwetter am
montag im norden und auch am dienstag
weitere gewitter dabei ein schöner abend